Long can a person be un-hybermectin and ortho-bendizle?
Well, remember, there's a few qualifications if it's not affecting your
liver or your kidneys in a negative fashion.
There's still limitations, so you would basically make that decision
based upon how well you're doing.
If a person is in, let's say, if my cancer is in remission,
and I'm doing well, see me lean, and maybe if I'm measuring by a tumor marker,
let's say PSA or my CA 153, and it's relatively stable, and I would say that my
cancer's not growing, and I have no other signs of growth, is there a time that you would pause it?
Yes, it is a drug. These are drugs, so they can't have other ill effects on your body,
so if there is nothing wrong with pausing something, especially a drug, you can start to develop
a immunity to the drug, and it can decrease in its function.
Everybody's different, not everybody's, this is going to happen too, but if I was
relatively stable and I was doing well, I think I would go on a little vacation
from the medications for a period of time, and then you could always go back on,
so there's nothing wrong with what's called paul seed, your medication,
so it's just something to think about, it's not right for everybody,
it's certainly not right for everybody to stay on it, it's not right for everybody to go off of it,
but technically, how long can a person be on Iverbecht at Infant Medicine?
There's literally no data out there, there's been no major studies,
as far as length of time to be on it. Typically, if the person's cancer is growing,
you're going to increase the dose of Iverbecht at Infant Medicine to knock this down and knock this out,
but if it starts to regress, and you start to go into a more stable situation
where you would say that your cancer is regressing or a state where all your numbers
are coming back to normal, this isn't something you just stay on the rest of your life,
so it's something to think about as far as the length of time that a person's going to be on it,
so that's a good question.